foreign
let's go to Sarah and the OC Orange
County California what's up Sarah
hi Dr John how are you I I was I was
great and now that I got this new insert
for my pen I'm incredible and now I'm
talking to you the home of Social
Distortion there in Orange County and I
don't know that things get much better
so it's awesome what's up
um so my mom told me that I'm the reason
she's depressed because is
um I won't be here for Christmas I'll be
with my in-laws
you are one terrible daughter Sarah
you know that's you know that's nonsense
right
yeah but but it hurts I know
why did she lay that on you in that way
she
like my whole life it's always been
um
like she'll use painful words
like what if she doesn't get what she
wants
um
give me an example of something she's
told you
just stuff like that and it's like in a
heat of Rage like like a red line almost
yeah
yeah but then she forgets it like and
then it's over with and as long as she's
gotten out what she wants
then it's like the conversation's over
and then if you bring it up how dare you
hurt her
yeah but then it's fine the next day of
course nothing happens of course it is
but if you bring it up then how dare you
keep bringing up the past what are you
trying to do
has this been your whole life
for the most part yeah
okay
I need you to hear me super clear
what's happened to you your entire life
is abuse and it should never have
happened
and I know people are watching this and
they're going to give me grief for
overusing the word abuse but you have
been responsible
for the emotional care of an adult
and an adult that is not that is is
weaponizing her relationship with her
daughter as a way of propping herself up
and that should never ever happen
and I'm sorry that happened to you I
want you to I want you to acknowledge
the depth of this because this has
affected all of your relationships
throughout your life hasn't it
I can't um I did go to therapy for like
five months a couple years ago when I
started doing boundaries my husband and
I are like a United friend
um
he's the one who actually told me
when we first started dating he's like
that's not normal
um
like for someone to yell at you like
that about
numerous different things and everything
and then we did the whole boundaries and
everything
um and it's worked really well but now
it's starting to
seems to slip backwards and she doesn't
like that I have boundaries of course
she doesn't and she says it's me putting
up walls
Hey listen
she has cashed in her votes she gets no
votes no say
she abuses you Sarah no more
okay yeah
and I know that's hard to hear because
since you were a little bitty girl
you've been responsible for making sure
she was okay she wasn't mad and she got
whatever she wanted
yeah okay and so practicing this
because your survival mechanisms have
been to make sure she's okay
so that you could be safe and not get
screamed at or hit or kicked out or
whatever the the the thing of the day
was
that's been taking care of her has been
the way you stayed alive and so
you learning to be whole and well in
your marriage and learning to completely
break this cycle and change your family
tree in a profound way
is gonna feel for a season like you are
gonna die it's gonna feel like you're
being over exposed
because this is how your body's kept
itself safe for so long
so yeah for me if I tell my mom like my
mom
um hey I'm not doing this thing I'm not
gonna be able to make it down and my mom
said that really breaks my heart I was
counting on you coming and
I would I would feel guilty about that
rightfully so I feel guilty that I made
my I broke my mom's heart
and I would also acknowledge her right
to
have her heart broken she's allowed to
do that she's an adult
and I would know my mom's not trying to
hurt me she's trying to tell me that she
really misses me and wants me there
when your mom says
you are making me depressed
and your choices are selfish and
self-centered and you care more about
him and his family than you do your own
Mom after I gave everything up for you
your body is not going to respond like
mine your body's gonna go screaming and
running from for the Hills
right
yeah the only way to heal from this is
to walk directly through the middle of
it that means put up your boundary
and when she
starts firing her weapons feel it
acknowledge it
be be as distant as you can create space
and here's what I mean by that when your
body starts to take off on you after one
of her email rants or one of her text
message rants or one of her phone call
rants
feel your body and as though you're
watching it from a ladder look down at
it and say man it is really trying to
take care of me and protect me
but luckily I'm an adult now and I'm
married to an awesome guy
and we're creating something different
so you don't have to take care of them
anymore because Mom doesn't get a vote
anymore
and it's not gonna just it's not gonna
be a magic switch but you're going to be
practicing this thing as you move on
does that make sense
it does
um there's one we do work at the same um
company so sometimes some of this stuff
who's that you and your mom
yeah has happened there like that that
happened at work what do you what do you
all do what do you forget what she does
what do you do
um I I run the office
but what's I mean what's the
like you're an office manager you're you
know yeah
um I would do everything I can to get a
new job
I would I would create some space it's
time
and the reason I'm telling you that is
is there's a physiological consequence
to what you're doing every day you don't
know it but you're going to work and
your body goes to war
it is scanning it is 24 7 hyper
vigilance it is making sure Mom's okay
let's don't do this because mom's going
to get mad I need to go in early mom
can't be there so I've got you see what
I'm saying the little machine underneath
your daily life is running hot
if you had one of these whoop straps
that I wear I can guarantee you that
your HRV would be low
I'd be willing to I'd be willing to bet
okay because your body is running hot am
I tell me I'm tell me I'm crazy like
you're an idiot John it's always awesome
except when she gets mad
it it is it's it's awesome unless if she
gets mad I mean she's she's just an
employee too you know what I mean
um and so I'm technically above her yeah
okay all right well yeah so that might
be part of well there comes a moment
when you say I don't care who you are
you don't like we're at a place to work
you can't talk to me like that
yeah or there becomes a moment when you
report her to your supervisor or if you
have the ability to say hey you can't
talk to me like that or you can't work
here
um all of that
is you asserting your right to be well
and your right to not be yelled at in
your right to not be
responsible for the temper tantrums of
other adults whether at the workplace or
whether at home
you know what I mean your mom is making
a lot of choices you cannot be
responsible for her choices to be
miserable it's not your job
yeah she can choose to go have friends
she can choose to oh my daughter's going
to be really happy for her daughter that
she married somebody incredible
and that they get to go spend time with
his family
she should celebrate you and cheer you
on even if she's sad that she's not
getting to spend Thanksgiving with you
that's called being an adult
and then she can decide to have friends
or I have a friends giving we're gonna
have a bunch of wackadus over it at our
house that's what we're doing
Thanksgiving is this week when I'm
recording this
we're gonna have people over my family's
not going to be here so we're going to
have friends over and they're friends
that I don't know super well and I'm
excited to have them over it's a choice
we made to not just sit at home and be
miserable by ourselves you see what I'm
saying
yeah definitely she gets to choose that
and you can't make those choices for her
the only person you can choose for is
you
and here's one thing I want you to be
very careful of okay you mentioned
united front
be very careful about not dumping all of
this responsibility on your husband
okay
okay I want you to practice
the belief that you are worth this
even if that means getting up every
morning and writing it down 10 times
I am worth having a life where I laugh
really hard I am worth having a life
where I love my husband recklessly
I
have I'm worth going to work and not
worrying if mom's gonna be in a bad mood
today
foreign to practice those things say
them out loud
okay
okay you got it this is the this is
Sarah this is the hard work of breaking
a cycle
God I'm sorry this happened to you
and for those of you listening I know we
have lots of Sensational calls on this
show
the reason I'm so passionate about this
because this is
these are deep sea planted seeds aren't
they Sarah
[Music]
I know you do I love them but it it
hurts because
it like makes you feel guilty
like setting them but then you you're
you're glad you set the boundaries
but then you feel guilty because you can
tell that they're hurt but it's because
of their own actions yes yes yes
choose guilt over resentment every time
okay every time
if you don't and let's say you canceled
your Thanksgiving plans and decided to
go like okay I gotta go be with my mom
because she's told me I'm the reason
she's depressed so I gotta go with her
and then it happened again and then
happened again
eventually your husband begins to resent
her and you
and you begin begin to resent her
because you do want to go spend time
with your in-laws you like them they're
nice they're fun
yeah I love them so you see what I'm
saying and so you're going to begin to
resent them and then it's hard to come
back
and so let's hold the boundaries up and
if Mom starts to yell at you I want you
to stop and say
I'm not going to allow you to yell at me
today when you're ready to talk like an
adult then I'm happy to talk with you
but I'm not I'm not going to sit here
and be yelled at have a great day and
then hang up the phone
if she sends you a bunch a long wild
text message and you see how long it is
just reply back I'm not going to read
all of this we can talk on the phone
later
see what I'm saying
yeah begin to assert yourself and you're
gonna have to practice asserting because
asserting has got you hurt in the past
and I will say it one more time
parents if you tell your kids you are
making me fill in the blank
you are choosing to participate in their
dysregulation and their distrust for
themselves and for for their inability
to
know where they are in space because
they're too busy making sure you're not
sad or you're not frustrated or you're
not angry you're not raged out that's
not their job they're kids
they're kids
and I mess it up too man the number of
times I've gone back to my son and say
hey I said you made me frustrated you
didn't I chose to be frustrated
because I'm an adult and you don't have
that kind of control over my emotions
and it's hard and it's something I got
to work at it's but that's what adults
do guys we gotta work at this
stop putting this crap on your kids man
because they grow up and they get
married and they don't know who and
where they are
it's not right
let's step it up parents
our kids need us